von links in millionenhöhe neue produkte
um verrückte innovationen natürlich
spreche ich von höhle der löwen wir
haben uns wieder ein paar produkte
rausgesucht und werden die heute
gemeinsam testen ich wünsche euch viel
spaß
[Musik]
und bevor das video startet ihr habt
gerade schon im intro gesehen tarmac
neue kollektionen 2001 alte pieces
geriet dort wir haben pari touren
online-check das gerne aus dass liebe da
und jetzt viel spaß medien herzlich
willkommen endlich zurück zur folge 2
vom ich teste höhle der löwen produkte
nachdem die folge eins so gut bei euch
ankam freue ich mich jetzt folge zwei
machen zu können mit wirklich deutlich
besseren produkten als in folge eins
auch dieses mal habe ich die produkte
natürlich wieder sortiert vom geringsten
funding bis zum größeren und
bestattungen mit einem produkt was dover
weise keinen deal bekommen hat ein grund
dafür dass sie keinen deal bekommen
haben könnte sein dass die 1,2 millionen
euro für acht prozent ihrer firma
angefragt haben was bedeutet dass ihre
firma selber mit 12,5 millionen euro
bewertet haben was natürlich schon ein
ordentliches brett ist ob das schlaue
oder gerechtfertigt war ihnen kein geld
zu geben findet ihr jetzt gemeinsam
heraus dass dreht sich um tricks die
leute die sich mit fußball ein bisschen
beschäftigen selber fußball spielen
haben vielleicht schon davon gehört das
ist tatsächlich auch ordentlich durch
die medien gegangen nach der folge im
prinzip verspricht dieses produkt was
ziemlich kleines und der lieferumfang
ist auch ziemlich klein dass ihr eure
fußball ist es wie in einem
professionellen fußball spielt selber
treffen können im prinzip könnt ihr
damit eure kompletten sets visualisieren
wie vielseitige antwort ihr euch im zelt
aufgehalten und noch vieles mehr dieses
kleine ding ist das eigentliche produkt
dazu kommt ein band in verschiedenen
größen dass sich um die hüfte geschnallt
wird wo dieses kleine gerät dann
reinkommt und was sie dann das gesamte
spiel bei euch tragt um das ganze aber
ausgiebig testen zu können habe ich mich
dazu entschieden zum absoluten topspiel
er ist es fc freya grund gehen für
geißler zu fahren 100 kilometer habe ich
darf auf mich genommen philipp siebel
hat ein spiel 90 minuten tricks an
seinem körper getragen es war
bezirksliga wie hätte es anders enden
sollen eine rote karte eine kopfnuss und
es wurde auch ins gesicht gute sache
[Musik]
welche daten haben wir aber
schlussendlich bekommt dafür trainiert
und erst mal vorweg es hat unglaublich
gut funktioniert wir gehen auf einheiten
schauen uns das spiel dann zehn zu eins
wurde gewonnen nämlich über sich wie
schnell wurde gelaufen wie weit wurde
gelaufen wir sehen wann wie viele
sprints gemacht werden wir sehen wo sich
im feld am meisten aufgehalten wurde in
der ersten hälfte 35 prozent vorne 54 in
der mitte 11 prozent hinten das hat sich
dann in der zweiten hälfte ein bisschen
geändert höchstgeschwindigkeit von 32 km
h jetzt kommt das was mich am meisten
begeistert wir sehen ein spielfeld sehen
wo sich am meisten aufgehalten wurde wir
können hier genau sehen wo sich philipp
aufgehalten hat und wirklich diese daten
die im amateurbereich zu bekommen ist
unbezahlbar und ich finde das produkt
megabyte 400 euro auch ein ziemlich
cooler auf fairer preis außerdem hat
super einfach funktioniert und all in
all den absoluten produkt in einem fall
dieser produkte hätte ich sofort
investiert wenn ich die möglichkeit dazu
gehabt hätten das problem
das problem viele von euch und auch ich
habe nicht die möglichkeit frühzeitig in
startups zu investieren aber es gibt
eine möglichkeit in große bestehende
unternehmen zu investieren und hier
kommen wir in folge eins auch schon mein
langfristiger partner das cable capital
ins spiel scalable capital ist nicht nur
mein persönlicher burka sondern auch
finanzfluss testsieger ihr könnt direkt
übers handy oder eine desktop version
super einfacher in aktien crypto etf
oder viele weitere finanzprodukte
investiert die counter stellung ist
super easy komplett kostenlos und die
können schon ab einem euro in aktien
kippten etf-sparpläne investieren mit
einer trading flatrate fallen die eh
schon geringen gebühren von 99 cent dann
auch noch recht wenn ihr also anfangen
wollen zu investieren neuen broker sucht
oder einfach mal mit der app vertraut
machen wollt klickt auf den ersten link
in der video beschreibung und ladet euch
gelbe capital und und auch hier noch mal
geht das ganze in euren eigenen tempo an
schaut euch finanzfluss videos an
sammelt informationen und das alles
bitte bevor ihr geld investiert wenn ihr
aber geld investieren wollte kann es
sehr gut sein dass alle kapitel der
richtige broker feucht ist ist ein
deutsches unternehmen die deutsche bank
steht dahinter und ich hab euch wie beim
letzten mal den finanzfluss broker
vergleich in die video beschreibung
gepackt in das gelbe karte als
testsieger hervorgegangen ist klickt auf
den link check das aus und jetzt viel
spaß weiter mit dem video das nächste
produkt nennt sich video wurde unendlich
oft von euch angefragt ich weiß nicht
warum aber scheinbar hat das ordentlich
wellen geschlagen ein klopapier
befeuchten
angefragt hat die firma 100.000 euro für
20 also einen selber angesetzten vier im
wert von 500.000 euro bekommen haben sie
100.000 euro für 20 prozent von dem
anderes als gast von wem anderes als
rolf deml habe ich jetzt schon 400 mal
gesagt also rolf deml scheinbar wirklich
der der könig dieser sendung erschafft
es zumindest wirklich die produkte dann
im endeffekt auch wirklich auf die
straße zu bringen und zu verkaufen aber
was ist dieses produkt eigentlich im
prinzip ist es ein klopapier befeuchten
es hat mich gewundert dass es so viele
angefragt haben arbeitet ihr wollt es
sehen also mach ich das für euch und
gesagt ernst viele leute geschrieben wir
schauen uns das produkt an gerade für
familien mit kleinen kindern könnte das
möglicherweise interessant sein werden
wahrscheinlich relativ viele
feuchttücher benutzt ich bin tatsächlich
niemand der das bisher für sich
entdecken konnte produkt wirkt schon
wirklich nicht besonders hochwertig und
design preis wird vermutlich auch nicht
gewinnen und es ist extrem einfach
aufgebaut
wird das zusammengesteckt mit einem
grundpreis von 10 euro aber durchaus
erschwinglich ich hatte mal nachgeschaut
für 10 euro würde man ca 600
feuchttücher bekommen das bedeutet nach
ungefähr 600 gekauften feuchttüchern
würde sich dieses produkt amortisieren
aber ich mache mir jetzt den arsch
abwischen
überraschung ganz kurze unterbrechung
max und ich haben super spontan
innerhalb von 24 stunden im podcast auf
die beine gestellt der findet ihr über
den ersten link in einer video
beschreibung auf allen plattformen
podcast trifft und auf youtube denn es
ist ein video podcast check das super g
aus was wir positive bewertungen da
folgt uns auf allen social und helft uns
dabei möglichst viele leute zu erreichen
ist mega cool geworden davon geht jetzt
eine folge die woche kommen am sonntag
kommt ein video zur entstehung des
podcast und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß mit einer stunde aber von jetzt
weiter mit dem video nutzung super
einfach unten kommt die klopapierrolle
daran die oben kommt wasser oder sogar
ein extra mittelrhein was mit bestellt
habe im video starterset sehr weiß dass
du näher ein wir ziehen das
toilettenpapier hierdurch wenn wir das
klopapier nach oben hinweg ziehen sollte
es eigentlich trocken bleiben
[Musik]
das auch der fall ist nach unten hin weg
ziehen sollte es eigentlich befeuchtet
werden
tatsächlich gerichtes nach aloe vera es
ist befeuchtet das ding ist es ist aber
ja nicht überall befeuchtet wie ein
feuchtes tuch mit welchem ihr einfach
durch mein arzt
einfach so direkt vom gefühl her es
fühlt sich überhaupt nicht anlehnen
feucht es ersetzt gar nicht das produkt
im prinzip ist das ein trockenes
toilettenpapier mit feuchten stellen
rolle in olten das klopapier ist nicht
sofort auseinander gefallen was meine
größte angst war auf der anderen seite
das produkt ist mega hässlich das muss
man einfach so sagen also wenn das
irgendwo in einem modernen bad hängen
würde würdest das paar irgendwie ein
bisschen zerstören und das ergebnis
kommt garantiert nicht an herkömmliche
feuchttücher ran was ich mir eigentlich
erhofft hatte und wo das produkt doch
eigentlich angreifen sondern also ist
soll ja ein ersatz für feuchttücher
seine rolle neu ist das für mich ein
eher schlechtes produkt von dem ich mir
mehr erwartet hätte das funding des
nächsten produkt hat mich tatsächlich
etwas überrascht das produkt nennt sich
black lips sieht so aus 125000 euro für
15 hatten sie angefragt wodurch sich ein
firmenwert von 833 1000 euro reagiert
bekommen haben sie 125000 euro für 15
prozent von abi ralf was einen
firmenwert von 500.000 euro ergibt im
prinzip dasselbe konzept wie pop sockets
die kennen wir alle ein media group
einen grip hinten für sandy um das handy
besser halten zu können aufstellen zu
können möglicherweise im auto sogar in
die lüftung stecken zu können und quasi
eine all in one handy haltung gegründet
von dem influenza namens philipp göbel
mit 240.000 instagram verloren zusammen
mit jim doran ist dieses produkt dann
entwickelt worden und wir schauen uns
jetzt an ob es hält was es verspricht
packaging finde ich tatsächlich schon
ziemlich cool ist ziemlich einfach man
sollte es in reinigen folie ablösen
anbringen und im prinzip ist man dann
fertig schauen ob die handy reinigung
auch dabei ist oder ob da gespart wurde
ich gehe davon aus dass ralf tummel der
könig des sparens ist bei solchen
produkten es ist tatsächlich diese
standards dabei die man kennt
okay das ding ist angebracht wir drücken
hier drauf können den fleck mit lösen
können denn dann halten haben in den
griff können das handy hinstellen und
wir schauen uns die nächsten sieben tage
an ob es wirklich etwas bringt und ob es
die 999 die das ding kostet auch
wirklich wert ist naja sieben tage hat
das ding den test nicht mal durchhalten
gerät ist mein handy hat keinen fleck
mehr denn folgendes passiert
kommentierte ice tigers geht der verrat
was euch sagen ich hatte irgendwie das
gefühl von vornherein das deutlich
schlechter heldt möglicherweise falsch
angebracht oder ich weiß nicht was das
problem auf jeden fall hatte das gefühl
dass eine pop rock it deutlich besser
gehalten hat manchmal habe ich popsongs
über ein halbes jahr dran gehabt und
geben ihren soll wunderbar getan dieses
ding ist nach drei tagen ab gefallen
außerdem seien wichtige dinge für mich
wireless charging im auto & wireless
charging mit meiner power bank die
direkt von apple klar allgemein während
halterungen die diese sachen miteinander
vereinen super schwierig aber viel grip
ist es auf jeden fall nicht größtes
manko ist aber definitiv zu stabilität
wenn ich den fleck tritt zwischen meinen
fingern hatte hat mein handy trotzdem
noch so komisch gebaut weil der
vlexgroup einfach nicht super stabil war
topfit würde ich sagen hat das problem
besser für mich ist es ein mittleres
produkt willkommen zum produkt mit dem
größten funding das aber tatsächlich
nicht das letzte produkt ist was wir in
diesem video testen namens independence
ich kann leider nichts in die kamera
halten ihr werdet gleich verstehen warum
angefragt waren 150.000 euro für 15 und
achtung bekommen haben sie 200.000 euro
für 15 prozent bedeutet sie mehr geld
bekommen als sie angefragt haben es gab
einen kleinen löwen kampf zwischen den
löwen und ich glaube dass das ziemlich
gut hinkommt denn die idee ist so
einfach wie genial war so einfach wie
genial über in die pendler ist hat man
die möglichkeit schreibtische oder
allgemein arbeitsplätze zu mieten und zu
vermieten was ziemlich gut ist das ganze
fängt nämlich bei einem normalen
schreibtisch an und endet bei der
mitnutzung einer riesigen werkstatt und
wir schauen uns an wie einfach und wie
gut das tatsächlich funktioniert der
witz ist man kann nicht nur irgendwelche
schreibtische buchen sondern wie im
falle von obi hat man auch die
möglichkeit sich in eine werkstatt ein
zu buchen und das werkzeug zu benutzen
genau das habe ich gemacht und das
schauen uns jetzt mal gemeinsam an also
die leitende agentur vom obi muss
ziemlich krass dem was hier alles machen
damit der eintritt in unsere werkstatt
für die nächsten zwei stunden
es ist eine voll ausgestattete werkstatt
wir haben ein standardwerkzeug eine
kreis erhielten verschiedene
schleifgeräte eine handkreissäge den
zweiten raum es geht ja noch weiter
komplette ausstattung für holzarbeiten
das begeistert mich gerade wirklich
krass ich könnte super easy das nächste
mal wenn ich ein bauprojekt habe nicht
super auch wenn ich mir erstmal
werkstoff bauen sondern einfach über
independent werkstattbesuchen also hätte
ich das vorher gewusst lässt definitiv
schon mal zum einsatz gekommen ich bin
richtig begeistert man hat hier alles
man ist halt in einem plattenbau mal
also für mich eine absolute 10 vom 10 es
kommt natürlich darauf an das ist kohle
firmen wie obi gibt die dann bereit sind
teil davon zu sein und coole plätze und
die arbeitsbereiche zur verfügung zu
stellen hier ist es aber definitiv der
fall natürlich gibt es auch gute normale
schreibtische kann man alles machen aber
das hier hat mich wirklich beeindruckt
kaum noch um das letzte produkt das wir
testen ist faktisch gar keine hülle der
löwen produkt das hat mich aber so sehr
begeistert dass ich trotzdem testen
wollte es ist tatsächlich aus der
sendung das ding des jahres was
basically das gleiche ist ohne das
funding gesucht wird das produkt nennt
sich vor zwei oder auch einfach reifer
super einfaches konzept aber mega gut
umgesetzt man merkt schon die 100 euro
die das rund kostet sind auch ins
packaging geflossen es fühlt sich
deutlich besser und man hat so ein
bisschen apple gefühl beim unboxing
viele leute mir eingeschlossen wissen
nicht wie man richtig messer schleift
und dieses produkt soll abhilfe schaffen
wie gut das aber tatsächlich
funktioniert schauen wir uns jetzt mal
gemeinsam machen und damit wir
unvoreingenommen sind zwei messer in
unterschiedlichen qualitäten ein
supergutes meistern das über 50 euro
kostet und wann sie in einem extra
messer shop gekauft hat und ein mega
günstiges messer für unter 20 euro von
regeln das ding ist beide sind mega
stumpf und können
ganz komplett vergessen dass hier eine
tomate der tomaten test wir kennen ihn
alle lassen sie nur gleiten ohne druck
[Musik]
jetzt aber zum schleifen das ganze
besteht aus zwei teilen einmal ein
magnet monat 15 grad schleifmittel
hinbekommen und einmal mit 20 dieser
magnet wird hingelegt kommt das messer
dran treffen so einen perfekten 20 grad
winkel
was hört es nicht gut an aber genau
warum muss es sagen
cool
[Musik]
also es scheint wirklich idiotensicher
zu seiner mit testen erst und das
günstige messer
war
krass 0 druck 0,0 heftig als wirklich
welchen unterschied und das ist das
günstigere messer krass gut das produkt
kostet über 100 euro das sollte auch
besser funktionieren aber das ist
wirklich cool weiß ich jetzt nicht und
jetzt im vergleich das 50 euro messer
aus japan glaube ich mit super guten
stahl nachschärfung ja auch das als
wirklich komplett ohne druck das ist
jetzt nur mit gewicht des messers
funktioniert super die tomate könnten
wir damit extrem gut schneiden
ich würde jetzt was zu sagen das ist
keine nass schleifen ersetzt okay also
ein mittel gutes nass live-set startet
bei 30 euro bitte zerstört mich nicht in
den kommentaren makatsch schon gesagt
das ist eine kunst leute lernen das über
jahre und jahrzehnte hinweg geben das
wissen weiter messer und so das ist eine
ganz eigene welt ich bin mir aber sicher
dass man mit ein bisschen übung ein
bisschen geduld und einem vernünftigen
schleif setzt seine messer auch für
weniger geld wieder superscharfen wenn
man eine super einfache
lösung sucht das ist dass hier definitiv
die lösung man bezahlt sie aber eben
auch für mich ist trotzdem neuestes
produkt ist eine luxus lösung aber es
funktioniert das waren mal wieder sieben
höhle der löwen produkte bzw 6 und 1 von
das ding des jahres ich hoffe euch das
video gefallen wenn ja dass wir gerne
vergessen sich den kanal zu abonnieren
und wir sehen uns am sonntag schon
wieder zu ich habe in 24 stunden ein
podcast gegründet der sache und während
er das gerade seht bin ich vermutlich im
freien fall was das bedeutet wird der
nächste woche lasst euch gut nicht
[Musik]